hi I'm Michaela and I'm nine years old
and today I will be having two chefs
compete to make my dream dish Kayla
[Music]
Murrell and I'm Kira
hi I'm Merle I was a tasty producer for
years and now I focused primarily on
vegan food wellness and sustainability
hi my name is Katara I was on season 10
of MasterChef and I'm super excited to
be here on I draw you cook so a little
birdie told me that you are gonna be
going to a dragons birthday party yeah
and as the dragon a girl of a boy a girl
hmm I love that she gave her dragon a
personality I feel like the dragon is
her know what I really need to know is
like what would you eat at a dragon's
birthday party I'm probably fireballs
and burnt trees with fire ants and
Firefly this gets more and more creative
as we go along what are they drinking a
jinking a lover ink she does a girl who
knows what she wants and I love that why
don't you go ahead and draw it for us we
have a big plate since it's a good
birthday party and then we had the big
fireball that there will be eating like
flames coming out of it laying
everywhere this is a person this makes
sense
they're dragon like to eat the fireball
because it needs fire to go on its
stomach so it's able to breathe fire so
it's the fire
yeah it's hot yeah sophisticated palates
dragon trying to keep up I'm just trying
to hear her and see her and imagine what
I'm possibly going to make what is your
favorite food in the world
my mom's spaghetti what is your second
favorite food in love I love this
fireball I think I got the hang of that
whatever lover it would be like a love
drink inside the drink is up and around
the brim okay and that's why L be more
of those rocks I'm getting very nervous
I don't know how I'm gonna do this drink
so we have the birch cheese right here
oh great she cuz it's really first Oh
such a SH that food doesn't taste very
good I think I can get really creative
and do something cool with those two
trees and then at the bottom we're gonna
have some fireflies and some fire ants
cuz these fire ants and these fireflies
will give them more fire sorry less
self-conscious empowering say Mikayla do
you think that we can make this for you
yes yes I have done a ton of insane
challenges on MasterChef I don't know
how I'm gonna do this we're gonna go and
make the best dragon birthday party dish
we can possibly do great so here's my
plan for the fireball I'm going for
spaghetti emblazoned with a fiery
bolognese sauce and that will be topped
with an escabeche multicolored peppers
and vinegar glazed onions for the burnt
tree I have tilapia with an
asian-inspired honey soy glaze for the
incinerator tree I'm going to prepare a
Cajun blackened filet of tilapia for the
fireflies and fire ants
preparing a fruit salsa and finally for
the lava I'll be making a dragon
surprise made out of grenadine syrup
orange juice pineapple juice a college
sugared rim and some multicolored ice
cubes for the rocks so for my dish I'm
gonna be going above and beyond with
sweets for the fireball I'm gonna be
making a super fudgy chocolate vegan
cake that's gonna be stuffed with peanut
butter candies and then topped with
sugar glass flames for the trees I'm
going to be shaping melted hard candy
and then dipping them into chocolate for
the ants I'm going to be assembling
strawberries for the body that will be
propped up on toothpicks for the
fireflies I'll be dipping popcorn into
melted chocolate and finally for my lava
I will be layering a mixed berry
smoothie with a banana smoothie and then
top it with nerds
are you ready for this how you feeling
I'm nothing yeah I'm nervous too I mean
it's so hot impressing like little kids
I'd rather cook for Gordon Ramsay than
for a night okay I do not agree with
that no cateura has a potential
advantage over me because she's been on
MasterChef she's done these cooking
competitions before I have not I'm gonna
be faking it till I make it my first
step is making colored ice cubes I'm
trying to make the colors of the rocks
that she wanted so she wants yellow
orange and like a grey black he sort of
rock oh my gosh they're marbled the
marbled cube BBQ so my first step I'm
making a cake I'm gonna be making a
chocolate cake for the fireball first
we've got some whole wheat flour I've
got some dark cocoa powder and I have
some baking powder baking soda and a
little bit of salt in here as well
mixing all the dry ingredients first
also don't forget my entire thing is
vegan that's a little twist I know that
Merrill has a lot of experience
preparing vegan food I mean I'm sure she
can do well with this I'm actually
playing up to my weakness right now
because I hate baking when I think of a
birthday party I think of sweets and so
to me a birthday cake just seems like it
made the most sense I think it's worth
the risk so if that doesn't work out I
am
now I'm mix it together all my wet
ingredients come in the milk some
applesauce since I'm not using eggs
excellent vegan substitute for many
vegan desserts now I'm adding quite a
lot of maple syrup into this as well
apple cider vinegar and some vanilla
extract I'm about to start on the
blackened fish
okay blackened fish hmm
use your imagination darling I've never
been to a dragon's birthday party but I
have nieces and nephews and I've been to
kids birthday parties and I've never
ever seen fish served what flabbergasted
I decide to cut the fish raw as opposed
to waiting for it to cook and then
cutting it after when you cut protein
war you're able to manipulate the shape
a lot better okay let's make sure you
[Music]
watch my hands I'm feeling really good I
feel like with kids they want sweet
things and I don't know if fish is gonna
do it for Michaela I feel like it might
be too much for wrists but that's
probably gonna come back and bite me
somehow
because like who knows next I'm moving
on to spicing it so it is a little
Caribbean Cajun Creole infusion so I'm
gonna put a bit of garlic powder put a
bit of cumin a little bit of cayenne
because it's a dragon's party after all
I decided to go spicy because her tastes
are a lot more refined from the average
nine-year-old I am I'll let you know if
you know what nice sweats that I could
pick it all right so now I'm gonna
combine my liquid ingredients with my
dry ingredients the smell of this is
making me think of one I used to use an
easy
I don't make a lot of sweet things so
this is very nostalgic right now Emily
last time you baked a cake
never well I mean like Easy Bake I
really never baked I don't have very
much confidence in myself when it comes
to baking because I never do it there's
too much that can go wrong why would you
pick something that you're not confident
that she should have just gone savory my
batter is mixed together I'm gonna pour
it into the two sheet pans I'm thinking
I don't have enough batter for both of
these I think I might add all my better
to this one well it's gonna have to win
it rises oh it's gonna rise I didn't
even think for a second about this
stupid thing rising and now I realize I
might have done everything wrong this is
why I don't bake is it as a stodgy mix
is it actually going to be flats or is
it going to I don't know good luck to
you kid I think it's gonna cake it's not
a day it's chocolate cake I hear you
sister
so I'm distinguishing between the
battery and the burnished treating it so
the first tree is going to have more of
an Asian Flair so it's very simple but
it's actually one of my favorite recipes
it's literally three items so it's honey
soy sauce garlic and then if you're
feeling fancy you can add some acid on
the form of lime or lemon juice put that
all in together marinade whatever
protein you're using and Bob's your
uncle fun is your magic hey presto fish
oh yeah with the candy I'm going to bake
it and melt it down and once it cools
off I'm gonna break it apart to make
flames this is so much plastic like
calming the environment I know there's
like all the work I've done to do
sustainability that's even reversed at
this moment if I crush them they'll be a
little more chaotic and then the ends
will thrill when they melt so it'll look
more like flames when i crack them how
will be you know this Wow I might break
this table though
so good here is the water to boil off
Spurr gets here you see spaghetti
yes spaghetti and fish I'm gonna be
honest with you I think this is an
insane deciding to cook the spaghetti
bolognaise is either the Slovak decision
I've ever made or the most stupid
decision I've ever made
so I'm starting my Bolognese I'm going
to use the Holy Trinity of Italian
cuisine celery carrots and an onion and
I'm going to you just fry that down give
it a bit of color and then we were at
the French chapter you know it's tough
when you try and replicate something
nostalgic to a person I am just praying
that her mother and I had the same
cooking style I'm not totally sure that
a big sheet is gonna be ideal for this
because I want to try to control the
colors as much as I can once the candy
melts so instead I'm gonna be using
three individual little sheet pans this
looks like a flame to me and a little
more does adding my beef mince and now
oh my god the smell so good I know you
guys can't smell this at home now we are
smart obviously you normally put tomato
paste in a sauce but I added a lot in
order to make it really vibrant red
because it's a fire bomb so to make the
trees I'm gonna melt more candy should
only take between like five and ten
minutes but once this heat added I lose
control so I'm gonna make an escabeche
is generally it's kind of like a Latin
dish I'm gonna go with some slices for a
few of the peppers and then I'm gonna
keep some of them in the half shape of
their in the space in the oven for me
okay right purposes well we've got one
success how do you burn flames how do
you burn in flames
I found a way oh my god that's so bad
that's so bad I will not okay
oh my god it's just like is that I had
like scraped the bottom of an oven that
I'd had for 15 years
I cannot feed that to her I don't think
we Glee I could be that hurt but this
looks like a flame you know what you
just have a high five that's magnificent
well done thank you I'm impressed so the
trees look crazy they do not resemble
trees the slightest they look more like
lizard keychains before you go about
laughing at me
too late I'm going to shape them with
this very sharp knife no I just heard a
popping sound on the top pop top I felt
so confident about these trees they look
like pretty much anything other than a
tree and I'm just getting so frustrated
oh good the whole thing fell apart we're
just gonna do this so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna just melt this back into
one semblance of a tree and then I'm
gonna cover them both in chocolate and
that's putting that to bed oh my god
disaster that doesn't sound good
how are they like right on the edge they
look better for just the nick of time
naturally if they've been in there three
seconds longer it'd have been a wrap to
make the giant ants I'm going to be
putting three strawberries together
that'll be the anatomy of an ant gonna
decorate them it makes it look cute
the ants I feel excellent about they
look adorable these ants may save me in
the long run to be honest the ants are
the only thing I feel confident about
this whole thing okay so I'm making a
very non-traditional salsa just sliced
up some pineapples red onions Tori's
some cilantro mango slices those hyper
salsa this you might be used to because
it doesn't exist and it looks great it
didn't overflow which I'm very pleased
about I'm gonna take this and I'm going
to portioning off three different layers
and
I'm gonna put a hole in the middle and
I'm gonna fill it with candy there's a
lot of chocolate and sweet oh yeah
there's only chocolate and sweets going
on here I was really nervous about this
part but it's actually going exactly how
I wanted to I'm really relieved at this
point gonna try the cake oh I think I've
rethought the fish shape so I'm cutting
the fish and it's all going awry I can't
seem to get the shape correct this isn't
going according to plan
okay that is a tablet okay that it's
French for terrible they're looking more
like toothpicks than anything else so I
am likely sifting some flour on set so
just give it a little bit more crust and
I'm popping them in there to fry they're
really small thin filets of fish so they
don't need that one I go I break a tree
to boil up broke a tree you're hitting a
little too close to home these are all
vegan versions of candies because
traditional candies are not so I'm using
yellow and red candy to go with a yellow
red scheme the difference between our
stations is abominable I am embarrassed
now I just slide the top of this on
there I'm going to start with the rim
for the drink for the lava drink that
she's requested now she's asked for
multicolored lava rocks so I've chosen
to replicate that with colored sugar
sounds simple but everything that we've
done today is sounded simple in our
heads I'm trying to rim the glass I'm
going to try it honey honey sticks to
everything right
[Applause]
this is an important moment I'm gonna
break my flame put on top of this flame
are perfect it looks exactly like the
drawing in my mind it couldn't have gone
better the inspiration for this Dragon's
surprise is a tequila sunrise clearly
we're not using tequila today so I'm
adding the grenadine and to the bottom
cherries some fruit to the base not bad
at all we've got all volcanic ash ice
cubes my only fear is that the more they
melt the more discolored my drink will
become but oh my god it's amazing so I'm
doing my drinking down one layer is
gonna be very banana based and then the
rest of the schedule I can't eat
strawberry raspberry guava what is gonna
happen when I pour this on top of this
is it going to just combine Oh actually
looks kind of cool I toss them nerds on
there too so I feel like it looks kind
of good I'm gonna make my little
fireflies it's just plain pop popcorn
I'm dipping it in chocolate because
that's what I do
okay good fish it's a lot browner than
I'd hoped for so what I'm doing now is
just planning off some of the marinade
to see I can get at the color of ash you
know I was feeling very confident going
into this and I'm looking to my right
and barrels cake is looking great I look
to my left and I have a saucepan full of
oil that I don't need that it's almost
ruin my ash I may have messing this up
shall we start placing see what we're
gonna do here this is what an adventure
this is
these crazy ants just need my little
fireflies on them yay we're good yes I'm
painting my trees this is the ash but
tree my spaghetti adding my ball in a v'
well it's looking like a fireball let's
focus on the sunset I'm really impressed
with the peppers you know what my ice
cubes have melted so it's time to Mets
I'm actually gonna make another drink
the kids it was supposed to look way
better than that
besides for that you know I'd rather eat
yours yeah he was looks better yep I
like wait a minute how did this happen
you had crushed candy and bun things and
suddenly it's this gorgeous cake very
nervous yeah I can let's go find out
what McCain is saying I'll see if I can
whistling whoo
overall I think my dish turned out
phenomenally it's got all the colors
that she asked for I realized that she
was very specific about that
so I tried my best to get as close to
that as possible I really love how the
Bolognese turned out it was absolutely
delicious and the drink turned out way
better than I could have hoped I got the
volcanic rock down to 8p I just hope she
likes it as much as I enjoy preparing it
this dish turned out a lot more chaotic
than I had initially planned but the
cake turned out amazing the flames
turned out exactly how I wanted them to
look the ants are adorable
it's very accurate to what she drew all
I can hope is that Mikaela can envision
this dish at a dragon's birthday party
bring out my dragon birthday dinner like
the fireball spaghetti this is all over
it looks a lot like my picture that I do
I'm so happy that she recognizes each of
the individual elements on the dish
[Music]
- but that in it's almost like my mom's
spaghetti oh boy I'm in trouble however
almost isn't quite exactly fish it's
good her reaction to the fish everything
I could have ever hoped school I
couldn't - it went a little bit spicy
which I really like I go any like bell
peppers you know I suppose if there's
one thing on the plate that she doesn't
like I'll take that maybe there's a
chance for me I'm very good
it's like those rock candies I think my
favorite is properly - spaghetti it feel
so cool Makayla loves the way it looks
I'm so happy
oh I've lost I'm lost it looked like
they made my firewall and - like this
big cake and Jamie like the fire ants
with strawberries - I think these are
the birth trees I don't blame Makayla
for not being able to identify the trees
properly fool flakes and my picture for
like the drink they got either like the
little rocks inside but they didn't
really get the color that I wanted I
feel like my dish is getting scrutinized
more than guitars IDs Edmund and him at
all I like it I really do she had no
idea it was vegan so I'm taking that as
a win Oh mmm I like the taste of the
things a lot of hard work went into
these flames I'm thinking this might
actually be the way I could win it has
chocolate over it kind of like a
chocolate coffee table a
throw it hard like scale I knew I should
have popped that popcorn fresh
I think it's lemon and paste kind of
like lemon or strawberry I really like
this lava honestly I'm feeling really
good about this I'm thinking maybe I
might win I'm gonna go home now guys
what am i doing it you easy some nice
tasty things huh yeah cool well I know
you had two dishes so which one was your
favorite the spaghetti or the cake I'm
definitely bummed out but I admire
Couture strategy because the best dish
[Music]
this is honestly my new my surprise
possession I think you've made a very
good choice oh it looks delicious
smile is the most amazing competitor
that I could have ever hoped to go up
again she inspires me to be a better
chef I'll definitely back so maybe I
won't be back here alright well let's
get to the strike and birthday party
shall we yeah
[Music]